or le départ tu découvres poitiers de la
voiture
patrice launay est un habitué du rallye
coeur de france originaire de romorantin
il n'a pas couru depuis le mois de mars
il a hâte de se lancer sur les longues
spéciales du perche vendômois
c'est une course du championnat trans
donc une des plus grosses courses ce qui
existe dans notre région donc c'est pour
ça qu'on essaye de la faire de tous les
ans et puis cette année location la loi
une skoda pour essayer
[Musique]
effet qu'ovide le rallye coeur de france
affiche un beau plateau avec 150 pilotes
venus de tout le pays
[Musique]
c'est une épreuve qui en général ac
accueille environ 80 90 pilotes
hélas comme la première le premier début
de saison tout le début de saison c'est
à dire tout le printemps et une partie
de l'été me aliou kane épreuves toutes
été annulées
les pilotes sont en manque des preuves
ils sont
ils ont roulé et ils se sont pour la
plupart il ya eu de très nombreux
ils se sont inscrits se sont engagés
parmi les favoris même s'ils n'aiment
pas trop qu'on le dise pierre et martine
roché d'indre et loire
la mère et son fils où le temps semble
depuis 20 ans soit en osmose quand même
qu'on ait confiance l'un dans l'autre
pour nous c'est quand même une chance
supplémentaire parce que c'était quand
même très agréable de partager des
week-ends avec son qui en tout cas de
mon côté c'est ce que je pense c'est
vrai que l'on se pose plus de questions
et des fois on n'a pas besoin de se
parler pour savoir ce qu'il faut qu'on
fasse comme on va le faire donc c'est
l'avantagé aux siens sur certaines
portions s'appelle à 200 mais bon c'est
très rare de sens et déjà la voiture
quand on est déjà 180 190 et j'ai pas
mal
le départ sera donné samedi à 8h à
vendôme le rallye coeur de france va
durer tout le week-end avec le retour en
force des actifs